oh my God don't do this to me no one is
here no one's here oh my God no one's
here hey hello everybody my name is
markip and welcome back to Five Nights
at Freddy's help wanted to I still can't
move this is a side effect of using this
and not the valve index it's not quite
there yet it's a
technological challenge to make the
buttons work properly most of them work
but I can't
I can't teleport for some reason I don't
know if it's just because I'm using the
wrong configuration or something but
I've got plenty of things here to work
with so I'm just going to go for there
babon oh that looks terrible I don't
want to do that fazer
blast kind of like the sound of that I
like me some fazer blast use a fazer
Blaster was it the fazer Blaster I
thought it was the Faz Blaster anyway
whatever hit your targets and don't let
the score fall too far or what or what
you going to be mad at me step step
right up test your skills and win prise
do you like dark I take
Las ever dream of soon the real life
SciFi
laser then you come to the right place
fazer Blast has got it
all just shoot the targets and take a
chance looks like
a contend hi ni
me matter and I don't care okay the rule
should be simple enough for you to
understand all right door high or face
the consequences that's the deal well
this has all been very
insulting that's what I always say fazer
blast okay thank you you must be a new
animatronic I can't wait for people to
make fan art of you you that's going to
be an enjoyable experience for no one
this is going to be tough for oh shut up
hold on let me think
here
no shoot Target hit the target listen I
paid for this game I can do whatever I
want with it it's my time you don't tell
me what to do you don't tell me who I am
I know who I am what are you waiting for
I know just get my bearings I guess wh
the power all right if you're
ready I'm ready wow oh
nice okay well damn all right here we go
nah whatever Let's uh do his casual
style skim my ey
[Music]
in what are you doing over
there I see something going
on
do I shoot him oh I see what I'm
doing oh no watch out
Freddy Freddy look out Freddy it's it's
horrible it's a black hole and meteors
don't
uh-huh
[Music]
uh-huh oh no I don't think that I well
all
right
[Music]
oh what oh I see
oh ah
oh uh sorry I didn't see you there chica
ah well I I think I missed one more
there a priz for the little ones uhhuh
next time bring the whole family for
once in a lifetime unre
barrier okay did I do
good yeah I did it I guess all right
what do I
get maybe it was a fazer Blaster I
thought it was a Faz Blaster well what
happens if I die I got to know what
happens if I die oh I can't control the
beam gosh oh no oh you're so
sad oh hey wait a minute I don't
see how this is actually even hard to
lose
I don't think it's possible to
lose oh my
God all right
well fine whatever well that was fun and
exciting and I'm really glad that it
occurred but to be perfectly honest that
was for uh Chumps and babies and I am a
man who's going to HS and craft daycare
I'm going to daycare I can't wait to
craft
the freak someone under
there
uh-huh also I don't know where the coin
would have been in that level use a dark
gun to shoot the objects you need sun
will toss them to you son oh don't run
out time son will be very upset okay
also what was that
noise there was a bit of a disturbing
noise and I don't know what to make of
that
hi no yeah it's me welcome to the
Superstar daycare uh-huh you're just in
time for arts and crafts thanks now you
just sit right there and don't
move fetch whatever materials you need
okay uhhuh use that rubber Dark Gun to
tell me what art supplies you need from
the fun fun craft
shells points and neck it'll be so much
fun y it sure will select that
brush huh so I actually didn't listen to
what you said so I don't know what you
were talking about Dark Gun
[Music]
oh
nipple ah nipple nipple belly button
penis kneecap kneecap all right what was
it sorry uh brush oh good job good job
now that you have a brush yeah gu what
time it is it's to find numers oh just
follow the Happy Little Numbers they
make all the hard color choices for you
when you are done hit the button and I
can evaluate your work H that's
awful oh am I going now oh wait hold on
wait what am I painting that or or what
what what am I painting
exactly
oh oh okay all right then hold
on well all right if it
oh ah don't you worry I'm all over it oh
whoops there we go that is a stressful
clock orange actually I had orange okay
orange
orange okay purple I know purple purple
guy shoot oh
shoot there we go yeah done that clock
get really stressful way before it's
actually time to be done so I I feel
like you should I don't know be a little
more congenial is congenial a term you
know yeah whatever I'm done look at that
that's pretty good works completed with
property of
entertainment for your next project why
did you shred
it forever and
ever all theary
mat if you don't see the item you're
looking for
[Music]
oh am I going now oh I thought I thought
it was another goof time okay I need a
mouth mouth thank you for the mouth
that's a nice mouth go right oh yeah
need eyeballs how did I oh right this I
didn't even connect
that all right
um hey okay
um uh oh yeah ear okay I need two of
those please thank you all right here we
go give me that give me that right like
that there we go and a hat anybody seen
a hat nope okay uh bow tie oh Bow Tie
thank you for that okay and yum that is
too stressful is that no that's a light
bulb the buttons oh wait a minute oh
wait a minute okay all right well that's
horrible
okay
cool these are white and do I need okay
white button in the center there hold
hold on hold
yourself hat thank you hat of course
couldn't be Fazbear without the Hat do I
just need to go for a bunch of these
until I get what I need I paint them oh
I paint them how do I paint them black
how do I how do I paint them black uh
maybe not oh God oh God hold on hold on
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh whoops y y and
yep I need many of these okay one goes
good God that's got to is that going to
be a problem wait these seem long wait
that's too long wait that's that's very
long uh where'd it go oh God ah
that's unfortunate for oh my God
okay thank you this seems too long but I
don't see an alternative I need eyes
eyes eyes please that's googly eyes I
don't know if that's what I need I'll
get some
anyway I know I know uh I don't see any
other possibility for eyes woo that's
not a lot of time okay all right maybe
maybe it is the buttons but it needs to
be painted like maybe I could make black
if I mix all the
colors no that's brown that just does
brown ah shoot okay I'm I'm going for
the go yes wait oh oh God okay I'm going
for it it's not oh that I maybe oh god
oh yeah googly I didn't even see the
Googles
time I didn't see the paint hello again
you're
back words get to it yeah okay thank you
um paintbrush okie dokie and bear great
thanks anyway I'm an
[Applause]
artist blue stars sure
whatever I am done look at
me thank you
and next project you know it
baby will be
damn it I feel like this is the right
thing hustle
and fcy
looking sh okay that's got to be it I I
don't know what else it could
be yeah rabit
ears and weird mouth
okay is that rabid ears no that's not
rabit ears what the hell is
that okay this got to be a button of
needs and then it is Googly
Eyes
yon and then bow
tie that's fine yeah that's the right
bow tie maybe I had the wrong bow tie
okay did I get creepy mouth in there no
that's not the right mouth wait oh there
they are oh it's like
holographic oh that's horrible okay cool
okay I need googly eyes rabbit
ears and googly eyes GOOG googly eyes
eyes I know I know it's googly eyes yeah
it's always googly eyes whoop one and
then oh
shoot oh
shoot okay there we go wh there it is
that looks right yep we're done
Wham thank you go
okay we really need to finish up before
nap time uh okay hold on um okay what do
what is what is's any of this that's not
right okay we got uh that's a different
bow tie we've got beak and a beak and
googly eyes okay we needed the googly
eyes I
I okay okay beak okay we got we got that
let's pull this again button button
button we need four buttons button
button okay one button up here in the
ear quote unquote this down here one
there one there okay that's good there
I'll paint it all afterwards not worried
about it right now there are my arms and
legs okay oh God lag oh why is that
lagging okay okay and then a bow I need
a bow before I get painting I need that
bow oh where is it that's a different
bow I'm just going to grab it just in
case it's the right bow is this the
right bow oh it is the right bow oh it's
a dumb okay here we go and artist art oh
shoot artist Wham yes Wham and then it
was orange there was some orange things
wham wham okay and then is that yellow
or orange that's orange okay Wham yellow
arm okay that's great then we got purple
right here and here and there and then
we got green right there and there
shoot
shoot there we go shoot okay and what is
that one
blue blue
donk I'm done taking
for well I did I did it I don't know why
you're jumping for joy when I you're
saying I took forever yippee yippe wahoo
wow oh
son yeah whatever okay thank you I am
very good at what I do and you are very
good at stressing me out so don't do
that anymore and we will be okay someday
I'll be able to go back there grab that
coin grab that
coin
whoa oh wh wh oh well what's the point
of this I don't see the point of
this
sure wish I could move around the space
but whatever what do we got to get Booth
nah we got staff
[Music]
makeup okay um that's
strange fazer Blaster
Western First Aid on Pig patch that's
nice the breaker room I don't want to go
to the breaker room right now I think I
want to do first aid on Pig patch or
whatever again what in the hell is that
noise I feel like I would have heard
that
before but maybe I'm wrong scanner
gun diagnostic monitor television how to
fix it don't I make too much noise Quiet
him with the gas mask okay so TV remote
for the
TV okay well it's a little strange I
don't know why I wouldn't need to make
too much noise first
a this training session simulates actual
emergency situations you will encounter
on a day-to-day basis the
state-ofthe-art Fazbear first game
station comes equipped with the finest
life saving tools their goal is simple
save the patient
avoid lawsuits and give the patient a
candy Fazbear entertainment believes in
the Sinker swim Training Method medical
attention begins in 3 2
1 the patient is suffering from parental
neglect avoid undo patient stress
according to Comic cards patient
outbursts bother pizza place guests all
right so parental stress that that
doesn't make any sense to me I don't
know don't know what that's
about shut
up shut
up shut up shut
up R the eyes Okay well he doesn't like
the cleaner in the eye I don't know what
that's about would you like a candy it's
a gag
order gross deliciously
non-litigious you want that
you want that what if I open wide
yon let's just get that down
there calm there you go buddy there you
go pal Hey listen to me buddy listen to
me really closely you're in good hands
okay I'm going to take really good care
of you and you are never going to be
worried about ever getting hurt ever
again because if you're dead you don't
have to well actually let me backtrack a
a little bit there you're going to be
fine and don't worry about a thing
because I'm your
doctor
okay ah nice
candy is this is this the heat gun
H seems to have been modified do you
like this ah soothing I
know very
soothing
there you go all right what's wrong with
you
okay
ah uh-huh okay oh you got the old dirt
hand okay so what am
I looking
oh what is this happy frogs pest
deterent pallets some kind of
brace mostly magical malaria morsels
that's great uh bucket Bobs itty bitty
butter bites that's
good Rockstar Freddy's chill cooling
chewable for children you want
some there you go pal okay how's your
temp well that's not where that
goes yep
get in
there come on hold on just just don't
tense up come on all right one more one
more one more one more one more one more
okay temperature is
nominal can I see those not tootsies
but whatever the opposite of a tosie
is oh that's
terrible that was awful that was truly
terrible
H okay that's was a success Oh yay now
give the patient a
candy done
binding I mean I kind of kind of have um
I mean you
it's there you go next scenario oh where
the patient is suffering from a claw
machine injury great news
due to today's successful Salvage the
value of the pizza place has
increased what was that glitch in this
or was that in re not reality but what
was a glitch there was a glitch I don't
like that
anyway
uh-huh
uh-huh oh you got a fever you got a
fever buddy you got a fever oh you're
not feeling so good well listen to me me
really closely I can't tell you if you
have a fever unless I get a thermometer
in you so you're going to need to hold
on for dear life because it's
thermometer
time one more come
on come on come on I'm going to get
it just one
second
okay come on on
now
uh
oh
uh one second can I get a hit of this
who my god
oh that's nice good stuff you're in good
hands hey relax
relax relax there you go oh vitamins oh
right of course uh you need some this
all right well that's easy okay come
here get this yep that's
awful the operation success hey that's
great oh that's awesome give the patient
a candy hey would you like a lollipop
would you like a lollipop there you go
that's you good
boy uh the patient is suffering from B
pit accident to call a patient apply the
relaxation mask until the Outburst is
under control be advised prolonged cries
may also attract the attention of free
roaming characters uh-huh
um whoa whoa whoa
whoa hold on a second there you
get oh what in the heck what are you
talking talking about what do you
mean what do you mean I didn't do
anything there was nothing that was done
the patient is prepped and ready no he's
not medical attention begins in 3 2 1
all right speedrun time patient is
suffering from trampled by fans oh man I
know that according to Patient
Outburst guests oh yeah uh-huh yeah
Hammer um yeah uh so hammer
um is there a hammer anybody see a
hammer around here anybody uh anybody
got one of those hamars and oh oh ah oh
this is not
necessary
later
sh I missed yeah ahhhh ah I missed here
we go this is going to be the
one okay all right if you're going to
keep moving I'm not going to be able to
do
this the operation success there you go
yay give the patient candy there you go
good buddy next scenario okie dokie the
patient is suffering from arcade related
injury great news due to today's
successful C entertainment value of
thecreed all right come here
you uh-huh the operation was a success
yay there you go now give the next
scenario the patient is suffering from a
slide related injury to calm a patient
apply the relaxation mask until the
Outburst is under control uhhuh so
you're pronged cries may also attract
the attention ofing characters
uh-huh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
listen listen we don't
whoa oh oh oh oh I got to look at you
maybe I could just you know get back he
doesn't seem to like it so what's wrong
with your Dome oh no oh that looks like
it hurts I know how to Bonk that back
into
place all right hold on here listen
you're going to have to shut up you want
some of this well maybe I should scan
him I
guess and that Bonk it's hard to scan
okay let me get a good look in
here oh oh never mind I know what to
do there you go the operation was a
success there you
go now patient stabilized
yay
yeah um okay I did that
oh oh we're done oh I I thought there
would have been more that was in I was I
was in I was into that I I was getting
into that
Pig patch it's everyone's
favorite kind of there's a coin in these
levels and I'm not finding them next
time next place I go I'm going to try to
find the coin
explicitly because it doesn't seem to be
working
Lefty
Lefty Lefty welcome back hey what's up
pre and
ready I can't oh man I can't quite get
that bring that a little
closer okay my
freaking okay thank you for that
oh today's successful Salvage pizza
place entertainment value has consider
oh my god oh oh oh my
God okay I'm not 100% sure how a bear
goes rabid um but you sure are aren't
you oh boy okay let's uh let's get that
out of
you okay calm shush hold on whoa he whoa
heyy come on come on come on behave oh
God that's not good sh sh
sh there we go all good all good all
good all good it's the rabies it's the
rabies it's the rabies it's the rabies
sh it's the rabies don't worry about it
it's okay so that doesn't look good
that's one of those scratch
things okay all right okay we're trying
we're
whoa all right no definitely don't
clench now n I'm not my I wouldn't do
that I wouldn't do that not to you I
wouldn't hey hey hey hey hey where is
it's gone it's gone hey it's uh well so
well well all right I suppose that's
what I deserve the patient is suffering
from oh parental
neglect oh God okay um due to successful
Salvage pizza place entainment value
considerably increased be warned
liability risk has also
increased oh oh well that was easy okay
all right then uh what's wrong with your
neck why's your neck all broke I
whoa oh you're
choking oh oh um uh okay all right uh
yeah H okay I this is the only way I
really hope I don't miss I've been
practicing okay all right I listen I
went to
Medical hey there you go that sounds
good hey hey why don't you back off
there hey maybe this isn't for you pal
all right uh should I oh wait we're not
done uh it
really and it's gone again ah you
haven't seen my hammer anywhere have you
oh there it is y okay
chill well if you can scream you're not
exactly choking are you
okay calm down it's fine so you're good
now right should i' take that out nah
whatever he would
[Music]
ask
sure to
candy
shush hey hey hey whoa hey whoa whoa eat
the candy eat the
candy patient is suffering from food
related injury uh-huh food
related shush
shush so I'm I'm starting to get the
hang of this and that's fine
um okay all right let's get a band oh
didn't that cute not that
one not that one not that one not that
one no no no no there we
go there we go all better okay well that
was
fun oh that don't look fun okay brace oh
operation was a success oh look at you
hey hey who who hey W whoa whoa whoa
whoa eat the candy eat the eat the candy
eat the candy that was not
cool the patient is suffering
from accident what is this oh it's like
a slap bracelet oh that's this is like a
slap
bracelet okay okay okay okay okay okay
all right okay all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
a get gone with you oh where's the
remote there's a remote
now all right you old Hammer application
oh turns out I don't need to use all my
strength all of my very considerable
strength all right and one of these
Shunk there you go buddy y there you go
now stabilized
yay
yippee I like that one that one's
[Applause]
fun oh good I want
him I I don't know what that's about
that's that doesn't that doesn't seem
good
um uh-huh yeah I would go elsewhere but
it seems like I can't because it's
horrible and awful and I'm apparently
going to the breaker room because that's
the fun thing to do push the handles
forward to complete the circuits and
charge the gauges use the megaphone on
Funtime Freddy to keep them away I hate
that what's with the tentacles what's
with the
tentacles I don't
know everything is okay let's go back to
see well I wish I could yell at you all
right well I'll get this
uh I'll get this I I'll get this set up
um
so so who
who oh this is awful I hate this
okay so we got
the the
baker I I don't know why that's a room
okay that didn't
work
uh-huh is that a hint is that what
that's supposed to hint at Okay
no
Okay I feel like that's a hint over
there on the left
oh
wait what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean I'm not I'm not I'm not
moving oh no thank
you go back to your stage everything is
okay everything's
okay everything everything oh oh my God
don't do this to me no one is
here no one's here oh my God no hey who
whoa whoa
whoa okay all right so what I got to do
is I got to pay attention to
these oh boy that's not good oh hi I see
you I see you I see you I see you I see
you okay hold on hold
on it's time let's go
back
oh my God where are you oh my
God oh my God oh my God I hate this this
is off oh nope no one is
here calm down I think you was just
a
okay I got a few on that's doing that
one I suing those okay that's good got
double on that one o r
sound as I'm going a little ham in this
room which I don't
like calm down and go back to sleep
no oh my God oh my
God
terrible terrible where are
you where are
you oh my
God go back to your stage everything is
okay it's bedtime let's go back to our
stage you must be hearing things
silly oh my I see you over there in the
dark
the oh what' I
do everything is okay let's go back to
sleep
no no oh my God nope no one is
here oh calm down I think you was just a
m oh my God oh my
God oh my God
everything is okay let's go back to
S there we go there we go that's what I
need oh my
God
stage I hate this is awful
no my God oh my God I see you over there
in the
dark oh my God I know you're you must be
hearing things
[Applause]
silly it's bedtime let's go back to our
stage nope no one is here
what oh my god oh calm down I think you
miss just
m okay what happened I tried are these
like connected in some way so we got the
parts and surfaces scooping room and we
got one up there that's not getting it
it's no calm down and go back to sleep
nobody here so it's got to be a
combination of this that I haven't
tried that's it God it was that one of
course it was hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on you must be here great
job tasks for the night
hey that I hated that yeah man that was
great Frick give me
that hey all right okay well that's a
not unexpected because that seems to be
the the thing that always happens here
um but yeah I'm good I'm I'm I'm good
thank you uh so much for watching and
enjoying this and letting me partake in
the five nights and Freddy's experience
this has been horrible and terrible that
but great good fun thank you check out
more Five Nights at Freddy's I've got
everywhere literally everywhere why
wasn't I in the Five Nights at Freddy's
smovie maybe I was maybe you didn't look
hard enough thank you and as always I
will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye